alors on va c'est un vieux monsieur qui
s'appelle guest mcg s my tongue donc les
photos de vos pieds c'est génial
devinez à qui appartiennent ces pieds
c'est une étape à mes pieds mais vous
pouvez participer
alors pour sa part mois des sept plus
facile oui j'imagine que la guerre moi
c'est pourquoi à mon avis
ça je dis rien volé la dérive blonde
s'était alors première photo
hi hi hi les fondations attendez
attendez à
bien et obtient un carnet à taille la
taille donnaient des groseilles et bing
c'est un pied d'égalité
c'est quelqu'un qui va jouer une équipe
qui est un petit budget mensuel autour
de 6 500 euros
pour ses pieds que pour ce qui est bien
c'est pas des mains et du reste c'est
vous qui avez longtemps c'est pas
pédicure ses soins du pied
eddy curry un lait végétal ensuite un
petit massage
pas marre de dépenser votre fric pas
tord et à travers comme ça quoi bien
c'est important ben on regarde son pied
maniche jamais vos opinions franchement
c'est très soignée bravo prétoire
[Applaudissements]
les suivants
et c'est bon
ça c'était bien
séparées
un peu marre on car oui c'est donc c'est
un peu fou non c'est bon ses membres ont
baissé ça mais on n'aurait pas très bien
mais que la tête et le pied prince pour
accor ça c'est vrai que ce que vous
dites est vrai parce que parfois vont
aider des personnes soit avec des jolis
visages et bruits ses pieds
c'est le rcd greenstein c'est
dégueulasse comme sa salle avec des
sauts à bout de chaussettes c'était
pourri d'odeurs
s'entraîne non c'est vrai ça et ça
marche bien et oui
alors j suivant my god
c'est bertrand
ce qu'était qui s'était excusé ce qui
nous coupent à l'eau de
mer excellent cheval la wii par les
sétois
cabine là
c'est pas très soigné
les pieds de ma tête
c'est vous c'est moi c'est pourquoi pour
l'instant on n'a pas assisté à
dire qu'il ya une graine que j'adore
c'est berthe aux grands pieds à oui ils
sont non eh ben c'est vrai c'était la
reine bertrande est sapé la reine berthe
ronde et la reine bertrand c'était la
maman de charlemagne
n'est pas celle annonçant avoir les
mains des mots
du la mairie bertrand tut et ils tuent
des civils non non mais c'est pas j'ai
voulu puis j'arrête poids paille est
plus un finisseur
finir qu'en baisse
suivant
alors là et
c'est quelqu'un qui mange c'est aussi ce
qui fait justement pousser très très mal
par la télé étant assez souple avec mon
fils tu as touché en janvier bah oui je
l'aï vu comme ça tu sais pour aller où
elle est vraiment on image alors
remarquera que je bous de chaussettes
à gauche c'est pas très soignée
alors vous avez le pire qu'on achète
j'ai pris la photo c'est une application
l'égyptien ouais c'est pas des parties
civiles et la paix qui dépasse c'est
parce que les grecs n'ont pu y c'est
sarah qui
remercie non je suis assez sympa ça
c'est le pied le pied égyptien très bien
être alors si qui est suivant leur
billet suivant
c'était beau magali magali bonvin non
non ça se reconnaît pas ce que c'est
effectivement ça correspond parfaitement
loup le correspond-il à coulon donc
parfaitement pour regarder la personne
alain regard de pied
de ces univers complexe et pas même
celles non parce que j'ai des mains de
peu de personnes de petite taille
doivent tous petites mains mais mes
doigts qu'ils sont plus longs que mes
droits mais oui
attention attention jours attention il
ya des grains de beauté fait contrôler
ses dépenses
contrôler les grains de beauté c'est
vrai au regard de boccia kane est très
important bondissant sai baba love
hewitt à pied les suivantes sont pas
vides hanté pied
on nous réunit cinq cent mille personnes
savaient la bernard je pense que là
alors je pense que là alors c'est
mickael y en a 10 ans fait ses pieds sur
la couleur de sa douce et ailleurs voilà
c'est fini
mais je voudrais quand même préciser
quelque chose parce que c'est ma
première émission et le premier
doublé le premier message de la
production que je reçois pas même moi c
est ce que tu peux nous aurait une photo
de ton petit à dire quelque chose comme
comme ak il ya pas mieux et en fait moi
je suis hyper complexé par mes pieds
parce qu'en fait mon deuxième orteil il
est je pense dans une relation amoureuse
avec mon trois énormes et sympathisants
satisfaction voix mais c'est le dernier
mois de définition parce que vos cheveux
sont trop serrées
tiffany besoin que l'on vous a pas être
vos pieds pour la première normalement
quand on fait une première mp on doit
danser c'est ça après je passe une fois
kanak je pense que je pense que paul
baumer coureurs vont faire connaissance
avec la avec ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est qui danse dans ce réseau
comme ça mais mais
mais il ya quelque chose qui génère
beaucoup
mais pourquoi comment tu tourne le dos
au tac la vallière mais oui non c'est
tout cela se fait déjà une très récente
messager du nez on se retrouve à la
casse a
annoncé travers donc de bienvenue et
baptisé
il reste que tu me fiais découvrir qui
suivra
la
bicici lagune aby couiza noms sont
amicaux c'est
mes pieds je déteste
vraiment vous faire plaisir l'énoncé de
matières plaisir mêlé de la nation je
marche énormément non je me pète
systématiquement tous les ondes ça c'est
un laptop soria this a
pas que dans les shows l'appui 5 l ua je
suis suivie au nom
et je fais ma confiance vous avez une
mycose
déjà que c'est moche ça va ça va c'est
maintenant on n'a pas assisté à des grès
de ses amies les bêtes tout le monde n'a
pas les moules à st il reste un pied il
reste un pari fait mal au hamas et mon
pied le choeur s'est montré ton pied mon
pied
c'est quoi cette photo là c'est
l'accident ouais tu marches à vous on
m'a demandé la photo de mon pied j'ai
pas assumer j'ai dit non non non non non
donc 6 août ont servi tout seul sur mon
à sa grave inquiétude
parce qu'on allait vous devez vous
annonce je peux pas lou devra y sont pas
faits
voilà enlever la chaussure
à la poêle à frire une boîte à tous et
un bon ça va
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les pieds cambrés là tu vois des
banquiers oui c'est vrai ce que c'est
les pieds sont la seule partie du camp
qui n'a pas été refaite
sachez que magali très libéré sur le
sujet pas tout mais perd même ambiance
et 9 des barreaux faire vos pieds quand
même on n'est pas à l'abri sa fiche en
matchs et j'aime bien les pianos mais
bon j'aime j'aime les regarder en gros
plan ça me ça me trouve pas sa vie et
non non non mais tu peux passer sa
maintenance et des bienfaiteurs du
visage affiché alors moi mon pays je
vous le dis mon pied et degen
d'abord d'abord jj si demain ça qu'on
doive fremm de peau quand je me suis
pété l'agent en fait j'ai une réaction
calorifique du pied donc j'ai eu des
petites attentions
c'est la chaleur oui d'accord
calorifique
coeur et c'est donc voilà ces petits
boutons rouges qui ont fait des petites
cloques
ma peau